you've won many grammys before but this
is the first time in the group's gospel
category how does this feel any
different does this mean more talk to me
a bit about it uh i'm probably
immediately gonna start crying okay um
uh i feel like it's
more important because i feel like this
is one of the most important bodies of
work i've ever been a part of been able
to do um this is what one thing that
i've wanted to do literally my whole
career
i've wanted to make this album and i got
to and
this just means the world to me
man i didn't last any length of time
today
all right next question
we'll go over there to the left
hi kevin clark from grammys.com
congratulations thank you um how did it
feel to perform ghost story for the
first time on tv i was nervous
um i mean it's it's nerve-wracking
anyway anytime i'm i'm on tv i feel like
when i'm in my live show um if i mess up
i have like two hours to make up for it
but whenever you're doing live
television it's like you get you know
one shot to just give it your all and do
your best so i get really nervous and
then you add all of the other
artists and musicians that
you know i look up to
sitting there in the audience watching
me um just adds on to the nerves but it
was exciting and
i'm glad that we have new music and
just excited for everything else to
follow
you